continua e perché ho il dito monk ogni
volta è sì oggi è la madonna un attimo
allora le quali siamo tornati su come
scasso già paranormal activity perfetto
non mi ricordo più come si gioca perché
passate una settimana però la torcia la
torcia alla torcia come fine è la
madonna ma era così anche l'altra volta
chi c'è permesso non mi ricordo dove
eravamo arrivati potrebbe essere un
problema questa anziché permesso
anziché c'era la bambina qua dentro
quando un ricordo fortunatamente gesù a
cellino a cellino perfetto che giochi
allegri che faccio sono proprio contento
ma dove dov'è
questo è successo
se devo fare sfugge alla batteria qua
ratificata aste come scegliere i viaggi
ragazzi perché ci provo beh non credo
abbia proprio una fisica incredibile
questo mappamondo però vabbè se vuoi lo
poso è ce l'ho preso ma c'è una cassetta
maledizione per avevo visto la cassetta
è questa no questo è un foglio di
merlano che dio ti protegge eccolo ecco
come si inserisce maledizione ciao fa vj
sono anna anna baker in diretta e stereo
benvenuto nella tua cassetta ok invece
di questo vorrei farvi sentire quale
all'audio vero
saluti a te famiglia sensi come come
aiuto perché vi compaiono gli oggetti in
mano io vorrei la torcia nella mano
destra la torcia nella ma grazie a
giocare a sto gioco un casino e meno per
favore che si apra le cose sì ho visto
qualcuno me lo sono sognato visto
qualcuno per forza o meno sono sognato
gesù cristo si comanda uscirà questo da
questa porta mi fate una cortesia a si
può aprire salve vendo libri gratis
questa è una situazione
guarda che vendo cassetta di anna baker
ragazzi sono serio sta la situazione sta
sfuggendo di mano dove stiamo andando
quante che non sa sta a casa quante
porte ci sono da dove viene st musica
schifosissima amaco c'ero già stato ok
però non c'è l'asta musica prima beh è
la sostanza perché ci sono due animali
che si ingrossano lì cos'è il vasetto di
nutella cos'è sta roba
ho trovato il vasetto di è la madonna
chi è che ha sfondato la pro non ho
neanche visto che c'era la porta
sfondata un mix il whisky il vestire
l'altra volta
eccolo ok raga almeno il whisky l'ho
trovato e già qualcosa
ti interessa del whisky senta io il mio
whisky non lo mollo manco sotto tortura
capito dato la mia mano nel riflesso non
c'è c'è solo il whisky vabbè che posso è
questo a è quello dottorato la cassetta
di anna è successo tanto guardare la
cosa più normale che ho visto fino
adesso va bene così chi è che rompe le
palle
no serio perché mi fate girare veramente
le palle se c'è scritto [ __ ] chi legge
ma tua sorella
ho fame ma che cosa è 6 mestruata
maledizioni sono entrato nella sala da
pranzo che figata
ma poi dovrebbe esserci qualcosa a parte
la finestra per uscire che il primo
posto in cui vado c'è scritto aiuto
sulla pensavo visto bene la prima volta
è una finestra sfonda la piana sedia
nola pio io maledizione mani monk e
maledette prendi una sedia ma porca
vacca c'e veramente alla finestra mezza
aperta hashino c'è una mezza aperta
prova ben a sfondi c'è anche la sedia da
ti stai già invitando a sfondarla come
la mamma degli età stein si apre non fa
nulla mi accontenterò di questa mattina
arrugginita ottimo lancio
[Musica]
gesù cristo di comando si si calma chi
sia aiuto ragas roba indemoniato e
partito l'azione bastati appoggio bene
mi fa piacere
credo che mi stesse dicendo grande fa in
lingua demoniaca grande fa vj mi
piacciono i tuoi video assistito proprio
fuoco anche la madonna va beh ciao bello
qua se qua guarda un attimo e arrivo
perché mi voglia un sacco questo posto
giuro
mamma mia che voglia che ciò è bello
veramente anzi qua facciamo così ok
perfetto e con questa qua dove l'altra
mano e jack 4 mi voglio male da 1 a
mille va giù da terra d'altro mi è
caduta la torcia lì che non ce l'avevo
in mano ma avevo la cellino però perché
il gioco dà per scontato che tu sassi la
torcia per arrivare qua perché sono
masochista poi vasco perché una casa
dovrebbe avere questa roba di sotto
botta c'è per caso tua sorella in casa
no perché era con la maniglia
vabbè ma stai calmo però questa deve
essere la stanza dei giochi
ah che bello ci si diverte qua è insieme
al milione gli amici
salve o del buon whisky di sopra con
lasciato di sopra per la luce ti guiderà
e ti premierà batte si è la vede un po
sciupato è queste citazioni della bibbia
però questa roba ma e pietro in costume
quad the beat quad axa e latino debito
fuerit r6 hus iscrivi to end mi piace
room la polaroid fame ad avola noi come
vede posso dare fuoco a sta roba mica
sarebbe stato troppo figo bel
estrapolare cerca di usare flash la
possiamo tre epoche al foglio posso dare
fuoco a qualcosa per cortesia ma io devo
fare qualcosa tipo di demoniaco qua
dentro devo tira fuori sicuramente no
non questo via via bambola voodoo
ma dai che storia datemi uno spillo vi
prego ditemi che la bambola di pietro a
piazza la moneta scusa che su scemo io
l'amore i soldi vuoi moneygram bird un
demone ma questi sono direttamente dalla
partner di youtube
sì ma lo fa qualcos'altro
prima ci va la fiamma
ma è tipo le ricette di cotto e frullato
ho capito arca di una vacca infame mi
serve volantino il volantino da melo ok
finalmente ho dato fuoco qualcosa mica
che un ora per la focara fatto o 100 g
di zucchero
quanto è difficile fare cose spiritici
ma l'iniziale equa ragazzi si interrompe
il mio video e video per spiegare il
perché queste scene dove io tento di
prendere la moneta ma non riesco a
prendere perché il sensore della play
non arriva per terra e quindi quando
vado quel mood per terra la mano nel
gioco non raggiunge il pavimento e
quindi non riesco a prenderla cosa del
pavimento il cerchio l'evocazione
richiede di fare delle cose tramite
oggetti dal pavimento e io non posso
fare questa evocazione perché lo
raggiungo il pavimento quindi dopo
mezz'ora e non sto scherzando mezz'ora
serie c 30 minuti pieni i tentativi nel
prendere le cose per terra ci ho
rinunciato è la situazione è stata
questa
una persona depressa ma questo era
l'episodio di paranormal activity io
volevo fare un ringraziamento anche
speciale a martina pelli che la
doppiatrice di anna baker che ha fatto
la voce della scena
non ci sono bambini in questa zona
quindi forse uno spirito maligno
ringraziano e grazie a martina che la
doppiatrice di anna e vogliamo fare poi
più avanti un qualche cosa di serio
anche con la sua partecipazione non vi
spiegano nulla perché ancora non lo
sappiamo ma stiamo preparando un
qualcosa di speciale
però il video vi sia piaciuto ragazzi io
concludo episodio cosa senza vi piace un
argomento che mi piace anche schizzi
anac sensore si rischia tre ci vediamo
al prossimo video belle ragazze
[Musica]